this property is rented we've just been
speaking to those that have rented it
they're from South Africa just arrived
the week before Christmas and they don't
want to appear on camera really very
upset as you can imagine but just wanted
to show us what had happened with their
property this is all their furniture you
can see they did their best to try and
get the furniture up off the floor but
given that the water came so high all of
this has been ruined wandered through
this way as well
the toddler's chairs being used to prop
up the table and the Christmas tree
being swept over with the water as it
flooded in did manage to move quite a
few things up out of the way in their
kitchen but you can see the silts and
sludge that has been left on the floor
we've been speaking to the insurance
companies and they're advising some
people that they will be out of their
houses for several months so this is
scary house Gary you had to come out
very quickly on Boxing Day morning yes
indeed you can see from the tide mark
it's a cast iron well obviously I put it
in myself with my brother my fitting
room you can see what's happened that
chair was over the far side of the room
it's unbelievable
oh yeah how's it looking it's not very
nice but to be honest we did up time to
get stuff up on boxes and get some stuff
upstairs
it's the silt isn't it and that is once
this is gone
yeah fridges and freezers as soon as the
water came up a flow to mend a flow and
the tipped over what's the plan 9 plan
now just been on the phone to the
insurance company they've been very good
loss adjusters are coming down tomorrow
just have a look but we've been very
lucky the Grange hotel on both and put
us up for two mates for nothing they've
been really nice appreciate that and the
milk that's ended up on the doorstep the
local milkman has been dropping off milk
yeah fantastic there's a real sense of
community and everybody's working
together you know how long you'd be out
for I'm hoping it'll be weeks rather
than months it's gonna depend what they
assess tomorrow but they'll come in and
do all the cleanup and everything and
this is because the flop area was opened
I don't know the details but as far as
I'm aware somebody open the barrier
Kista they were worried about the pumps
been shut down I mean if you build the
pumps for flooding below flood level it
seems to me a bit ridiculous I don't
know what don't know what the situation
is that I leave you to it thanks thanks
a lot
so as I was saying this is the the
reality of opening flood gates and water
pouring into dozens in fact hundreds of
houses here in York this beautiful floor
completely ruined along with many
thousands of pounds of belongings as
well so this is 36 watch your step as
you come through at 36 34 we've been in
- ruined as well
32 ruined as well
30 on and on and on it goes weeks if not
months to recover